lucky cat for me is almost like a
collection of two and half decades of
travel taste experience coming into one
magical room one of the most exciting
parts of lucky cats is experiencing the
most amazing dinner on the chef's tables
now these are positioned inside the
kitchen you start to see the technical
skill in the craft delivered across
every dish the menu will be almost
orchestrated around what you would like
to see and tailor-made to what you want
to experience across that an incredible
array of amazing ingredients so it's the
best seat in the house one of the most
exciting kitchens anywhere in London and
you'll understand
I suppose the magic behind the madness
on the combinations the menu is one of
the most exciting menus I've had a
chance to put together with been across
all my travels through Asia one thing
that struck me was the sharing plates it
makes you so much more intimate
so the dishes are designed to hit the
center of the table and it's almost like
the most glamorous pick-and-mix because
you can depend apart as you please
whether it's the most amazing eel
scallop duck that level of enjoyment
from the centerpieces in the middle of
the table is something that you never
get tired of backed up with an
incredible cocktail bar with something
so the best collection of sake anywhere
on the planet what's the twist you bring
to this style of food the different
flavors from different parts of Asia so
it's not sticking one with one regiment
two cuisine we're just gonna say the
usually works with the scallop so we're
gonna do it we're gonna make the hot
sauce why not which sounds outrageous
why does it work it works cause it's
it's been tried and tested we've tried
up a long time we've worked in a dish
for a long time yeah favorite cocktail
tonight we're serving is what for me
they're lucky Negroni it's something
really really special you've got a dice
roll for the guests and essentially
they've got 216 different combinations
of how they can have the drink so it's a
really cool and quirky cocktail that we
can do now I know that service and food
go hand in glove what you're hoping for
hospitality and warmth it's inviting us
into your house that's it yeah for me
that's cute
it's just a magical theater there is
precision beyond belief smooth
sophisticated and certainly not
intimidating
I'm so excited launch lucky cap now for
regular updates please go to lucky cats
by Gordon Ramsay on Instagram and I
can't wait to show you what it's all
about
you